and we're live hello everyone welcome to
another YouTube hangout I'm really
excited to have my friend and elite
author on my website deep curling here
with me to talk about how to be better
at sales and he's written a new book
called the 63 powerful sales and sales
management tips to increase your sales
it's a free ebook and we're going to get
into some of the details and also answer
some questions on how to improve your
sales Kaza sales sales for yourself as
an entrepreneur and also people who
might be hiring on your team as sales
people so Dave welcome back thanks Evan
it's great to be back
appreciate the invitation I love it now
one of the one of the key things you're
talking about in the book is it's a lot
easier than people think to be good at
sales to be gonna sell in to be a good
sales manager part of the message you
have to believe in yourself could you
elaborate on that a little bit what are
the things that are tripping people love
why is it so much easier than people
think how can I get better well one of
the neat things in this book is that I
took a series of 30 or so articles that
I've written over the last 10 years
about my son and these articles started
when he was 3 and they continued till he
was about 12 or 13 so it might have been
two or three a year where I'd see him do
something that just caused me to shake
my head and go wow and I'd make a
connection between that thing he did and
something that salespeople did so
there's a lot of analogies and in each
case it's usually revolving around
something that he didn't know that he
couldn't do he had no reference to think
that he couldn't do anything so a lot of
these articles are about the belief
systems that entrepreneurs and
salespeople and sales managers have
where they automatically think I can't
do that that's too difficult that's too
challenging that's too scary
that won't work and my son doesn't know
those things he can do anything and you
know today he's 13 nothing stops him
so I take some of his lessons and
translate them to entrepreneurship and
to sales and to sales management to show
how easy it is to do the things that
you're not currently doing because the
only thing in the way is between your
ears I love it I love it
I fully believe that every time I've
made a significant growth in my business
it's it's come from shattering a
limiting personal belief of mine and I
remember one related to sales in my
first company I was 19 years old and I
was selling to researchers and PhDs and
people who make me three times my age
and have way more education and thought
they're never gonna listen to me I'm
just this 19 year old kid and I was
afraid to talk to them and it wasn't
until I realized hey they don't care how
old I am as long as I can provide value
to them that then I started getting more
calls and getting more deals and signing
more customers onto the company it was
all up here like you said has nothing to
do with them was all up here so what
what are some of the what are some of
those stories what are some of the
limiting beliefs that you find that
entrepreneurs and salespeople managers
have that maybe some of the most common
ones that they need to break free from
well one of the stories that I tell in
the book and it's a great one as to
crashing through beliefs he was about
seven years old and we had a small
snowstorm and I went out to shovel and I
asked him if he wanted to help in this
particular time for the first time he
said sure so he grabbed a shovel I
grabbed a shovel and together we
shoveled the two long walks that we have
we also have a big circular driveway in
front of the house and he said aren't we
gonna do the circular driveway and my
reference was no freaking way too much
that's for the snow blower or the snow
plow so I said geez I don't think so he
said why not we can do that fast daddy I
said okay I didn't want to crush his
belief that it could be done I know I
would never do it myself so we went out
and in 15 minutes we had that whole
circle all shoveled because he didn't
know that he couldn't do it so I
I use that as a jumping off point to
talk about some of the things that
salespeople think they can't do and
entrepreneurs think they can't do and
how easy it is to do those things if
they just change the decision if they
just change the belief if they just turn
it into an affirmation instead of
sabotaging themselves got it another the
the story I start the book off with is
one of my favorites he was three years
old this was the first article that
started these sales people are just like
children series so he and I were driving
in the car and I turned around to him he
was in the car seat and I said would you
like to go shopping with me tonight so
that you can get a Christmas gift for
mommy and he said yes I said what would
you like to get her and he immediately
said I think she should like a
pocketbook and my thinking was wow he's
only three but he's seen the gift-giving
thing enough so that he automatically
knows to think of what she would like
and before I was even done thinking that
thought he said or maybe she should like
a train set for me and and the
connection there is that even with
entrepreneurs and salespeople you can
get them thinking about the other person
the prospect for a little bit of time
but it's not long before the band snaps
back and they're back to thinking about
themselves and what they want out of the
meeting and so the analogy is that you
need to stay focused on the other person
you need to listen you need to ask
questions you've got to find out what
they care about and it has nothing to do
what with what we care about I love it
are there some common ones that you find
for entrepreneurs and salespeople
managers that really hold them back in
their positions yeah
common beliefs the the single biggest
set of common beliefs that that they all
have entrepreneurs salespeople sales
managers revolve around money and
whether or not it's okay to talk about
it and whether or not it's okay to push
about
and how much money is a lot and whether
they're choking point on money is high
enough for what they're trying to sell
and how much money they need to ask for
probably the biggest ones are about
money another big one is about how
important it is to be liked it's it's
really tough because the salespeople who
are the most personable we're most
friendly most effervescent who are loved
by all their friends who are encouraged
to go into sales have the hardest time
because while they can make friends they
can't separate that need to have people
like them from the need to get those
people to buy from them hmm
and the need to be liked takes
precedence over the need to do business
and it's ok to be liked and it's OK to
get people to like you but you have to
stop at need so if you like me Evan
that's awesome
but I don't need you to like me I don't
care if you don't like me
cuz I've got questions I need to ask you
and if I'm worried about whether you
like me I won't be able to ask those
tough questions because I'll be worried
that you won't like me anymore so that's
that's another huge common belief
problem 54% of the people in sales have
strong enough need to be liked so that
it sabotages them Wow and so you know I
guess first step is just the awareness
that this is a belief a mindset a habit
that you have once that's on your radar
how do you then go about fixing it
changing it great question and there are
a few things that we can do number one
we can replace the need to be liked with
a need to be respected and and you gain
respect from asking intelligent relevant
useful tough questions from pushing back
and challenging somebody's thinking and
being valuable to them the second thing
you can do is you can kind of fill up
your tank on love before you start
selling for the day so you know get a
golden retriever and let them love you
to death
the kids your spouse or your significant
other get it fill the tank before you
come to work and third thing this is
this is I love this one
the author Dan Millman he wrote the way
of the Peaceful Warrior and they made a
movie out of that book and he's written
12 books since then he shared this one
with me for my book baseline selling and
his suggestion is to build a shrine and
it's called the what'll shot shrine okay
you stand before the shrine in the
morning and you say - what'll what'll he
think of me what'll we do if I ask this
question
what'll II think if I have this really
tough question what do you think about
the way I look today and and have
what'll just debunk all of that need to
be like just make a farce out of the
whole thing so that it's not important
there also some great books that people
can read to help him through this need
to be liked Millman's book the way of
the Peaceful Warrior is one
he's also got another one that's good
called ordinary moments talk to Wayne
Dyer one of his early books before he
was a New Age guy one of his early books
was called your erroneous zones and
that's got some great stuff on
overcoming need for approval and and if
it's really strong and nothing else
works therapy interesting now what about
money so the you let off with money
being a big issue people don't know how
much to ask they may not value
themselves enough they have thresholds
over you know where they feel
comfortable how do you so first step you
know maybe you read you read the book
you get this the awareness that okay I
have limiting beliefs about money how do
I then go about fixing those in the same
step so there other steps that might be
helpful different I found monopoly helps
a lot okay
play with monopoly money but you have to
imagine
it's real currency and you have to just
talk about the money you have to play it
out loud not just play the game but play
it out loud and discuss how much money
you have and how much money your
opponents have and what they're doing
with the money and just get talking
about the money so much that it becomes
second nature and you get numb to it so
that when you're in front of a
prospective customer and it's time to
talk about money
you've been talking about money for
weeks and weeks and weeks it's no big
deal anymore see you can say are you
willing to invest a hundred thousand
dollars on this great new technology
that'll solve this set of problems
you've been having and not flinch do you
find that when you're then managing
people if you're managing a sales team
or you're bringing on your first
salesperson that you're limiting beliefs
get passed on to them yeah yeah that
that's a great insight and that's one of
the things we look at when we evaluate
sales managers is which self limiting
beliefs that they have that might
influence what their salespeople do for
instance one of the self limiting
behaviors that have a great effect on
selling is the way people buy and there
are a few components that make up what
we call buy cycle so that's whether or
not they need to think things over
whether or not they need to comparison
shop whether or not they price shop
whether or not they do research and the
one we already talked about how much
money is a lot and if if we're in a
price sensitive business and there's a
lot of price competition and the
prospect wants the lowest price and the
salesperson is someone who would
ordinarily go out and shop for the
lowest price salesperson understands now
if they go back to the manager and says
I need a better price instead of digging
in and selling value right they can't
and the manager has that same tendency
to go out and look for the lowest price
then then the manager is enabling the
salesperson to just give everything away
whereas if at least the manager didn't
have that self limiting behavior and the
manager bought value the manager could
say whoa wait a minute why are we doing
that what's what's going on here what
happened to our strategy that we're
gonna sell value and that we're not
going to be commoditized we're not gonna
compete on price where did that go and
and that can lead to a good coaching
conversation so when you are screening
because you'll help companies hire
salespeople and train them when you're
screening them do you do you try to get
that information out of them how much
the comparison shop themselves how much
they look for value in what they're
buying our assessments ask questions
about how they buy so that we can
project how that's gonna affect them on
the phone and in the field when they're
selling interesting so that's all part
of their sales DNA yeah cool interesting
you can learn skills you can learn
strategies you can learn techniques but
if the sales DNA isn't supportive of
doing those strategies tactics and
techniques then they don't get executed
so selling has a lot more to do with the
DNA and whether it's supportive than it
does with the skills which they may or
may not have interesting I like that
they've david goes deep on this one I
like it out of here so we've got people
watching and these you change one of
your beliefs didn't you which one that
the Toronto Blue Jays will always suck
Toronto Blue Jays are gonna win it all
and look at them this year always this
day we'll see we need to the woods gonna
get healthy again yeah Manish is writing
is was so finishes watching live and is
asking about selling in a selling em new
product that that hasn't been sold
before in a new country or new city your
steps to create awareness and promoting
something that has never been sold
before is it was that
same is a different with with knots I
had it's different its you have no
competition that's the good part the bad
part is there's no awareness your
awareness that there's a need for this
there's no awareness that it exists and
the tendency is to run out and tell
everybody all about what it does and how
well it does it and people say thank you
very much that's good to know they don't
buy it so you have to take an approach
that anybody selling an existing product
or service might take and that's a more
consultative approach and that's
starting to ask questions about whether
or not they have the symptoms of the
problem or the challenge or the
frustration that this new product
technology would solve so you have to
create the need when it's a new product
or a new technology good next question
coming in is do you have a Dave do you
have advice on how to close the deal yes
I have advice on closing the deal you
know there there are several pure
selling competencies that are really
important to talk about so one is one's
ability to hunt for new business find
the opportunities to is the ability to
sell consultative ly and create the need
3 is the ability to qualify for is the
ability to present the right things to
the right people at the right time for
the right reasons and 5 is posturing
that's your ability to differentiate
yourself and be memorable and 6 this
closing and historically when we
evaluate salespeople and we evaluate
sales forces the closing competency
scores the worst mmm if if the scores
are in the 60s 70s and 80s on the other
competencies will see closing competency
scores in the 30s or the 20s it's it's
generally horrible across the board and
that's okay you don't have to be a great
clothes
if your graded all the things that
happen before closing so if you're great
at finding opportunities and the
pipeline's always filled so you don't
have this incredible need to close the
one opportunity you have and pressure
them if you're good at taking a
consultative approach and uncovering the
compelling reason why someone would buy
from you if you're good at
differentiating and qualifying to make
sure the opportunity is real and you're
good at taking all of that information
and leveraging it into a quality
compelling proposal or presentation then
it'll close itself and you don't need to
be a great closer but if you suck at all
those other things and you don't have
enough opportunities and you didn't
leverage them the right way and you
didn't set them up the right way then
you better be good at closing because
that's the only hope you have left so
just to give you an example on closing
who asked that question ah Sanjay Sanjay
ultimately hears the most powerful
closing question on the planet okay it's
three questions the first question is do
you believe I understand your problems
and if you did the right things earlier
in the in the sales call or the sales
meeting the prospect has to say yes the
second question is do you believe I have
the expertise to solve your problem and
again if you ask the right questions and
you did the right things they would have
to say yes
and given yes the answers to those first
two questions your last answer is do you
want my I'm sorry the last question is
do you want my help so that's totally
unlike all the other closes you might
read about or see in a video but that's
all you need so what I need you to think
about is how does the conversation
you've been having with your prospects
need to change in order to get to the
point where you can ask those three
questions and get the business by asking
those three questions because clearly
those three questions won't work if
you've just been presenting
your product of your service those three
questions are totally out of context if
you're doing that but if you're asking
the right questions and you're having a
great conversation and this good give
and take and there's flow and you're
challenging them and you're adding value
and you're being value and they're
properly qualified then when you get to
that point those three questions seal it
just like that
cool salvadore I'm running the clothing
brand and my sales are kind of low what
can I do and how can i market myself
better that's a great question
it would help to know whether we're
selling the clothing brand to retail
stores or we're selling it online or
we're out on the street with a stand and
or trying to sell and sell black market
stuff to the people walking by can you
tell us who you're selling the clothing
line to and then I can give you a better
answer because at first blush it sounds
like a marketing problem not a sales
problem
okay so Salvador if you're still there
follow up next one was Dave do you
believe in bulk SMS and email do you
think these kinds of strategies really
create sales no they don't create sales
but that doesn't mean you shouldn't do
some email and do some bulk SMS if if
the message is and the emails are going
to your target audience and not just to
anybody with an address and if they're
engaging if they're short engaging and
they can get people's interest and they
address a problem that these people
might have then maybe you'll get some
people to raise their hands once in a
while and then you can start the sales
conversation they aren't gonna sell for
you unless you're selling some really
low price no-brainer online subscription
but if you've got something to actually
sell then you need to have an
opportunity to start the sales
conversation on the phone not behind an
email or a text message cool does Dave
have a youtube channel yes
what the link is oh but it is out there
I'm sure if you did a youtube search for
Dave Carlin it would come right up
they've grown YouTube cool okay you are
LAN yeah guys it's in the title to these
Dave's whole name is in the title if you
check it out and his informations in the
description
how important is environment you know in
terms of creating the mindset and
changing your mindset right like this
guy is here for a reason and this is on
the wall for reason they look in your
office and we've talked about before
with the base Falls are there for ease
and everything you created there is
there for a reason how important does
your environment shape your thinking and
your mindset and maybe potentially help
you overcome limiting beliefs that you
have that's a fabulous question I think
the environment is really important I've
got my wall for my walls are plastered
with baseball memorabilia with the
occasional Tom Brady with a deflated
football thrown in for good measure and
it makes me want to be here it makes me
happy to come into my office it makes me
happy to work here see it should not
only create a little personal personal
work area that makes you happy that puts
you in the right frame of mind but if
you're selling on the phone a couple
important tips or you should always be
standing up and you should always be
looking up because one I don't know if
we can demonstrate this really good but
if I took the phone and I did what most
people do put my elbow down on my desk
and lean look at the physiology of that
posture that's the posture of depression
it's really hard selling over the phone
even if it's just to schedule an
appointment selling over the phone is
brutally difficult these days ok it's
really hard to get through people don't
answer their freakin telephones anymore
they don't return calls so if you do
finally get somebody on the phone you
want to be able to maximize optimize
leverage the fact that you've got
somebody to talk to
thing you want to do is sound miserable
on the phone so you've got to
immediately get somebody's attention
immediately get them interested in the
best way is to sound like somebody they
want to talk to not somebody they want
to get off the phone
so by standing up and and looking up at
the ceiling I better go back far enough
so you can see me if you can't even cry
if you're looking up in the ceiling it's
physiologically impossible so it brings
you to life you can be more expressive
you can be more engaging and you can
sound more like that person that the
other person on the other end of the
phone would choose to speak with rather
than choose to hang up on cool I love it
I know we're kind of bumping up against
the clock there's still a lot more
questions Matthew J Manish Vinicius
Salvador I think to wrap it up we want
to talk about Dave's book and it's a
free ebook that you're giving away and
the best way for them to reach you is it
by email is that how you want people to
reach out to you yeah if they send me an
email then I can respond with a link to
get the free download that'd be the
easiest thing to do okay so the easiest
email address to get me at is Dave at
baseline selling calm be that email
address still works I haven't used it
for a while email some people and the
bounces and they all bounced back let me
just send myself a test email to make
sure that works cool yeah so that's a
free ebook it's 63 powerful sales and
sales management tips to increase your
sales I'll put the link in the email
below there's more about they've down
there with all the other questions if
you want to get them today by email I'm
sure he'll be happy to respond to some
of them as well Dave thank you so much
for spending the time today was my
pleasure Evan thanks for inviting me and
having me back on your hangout alright
we'll have to do it again yeah and I
will be happy to answer anything that
comes to me by email okay perfect thank
you I love dress works Dave at baseline
selling calm I love it and go Jays go
yeah hope to see him in the World Series
- I know